I've been looking at
you putting holes in your
head we've been talking for
months but never in the same
room now I want to approach
you but we've been keeping this a
secret and you're surrounded by
friends and I'm just wondering what they
know I wish you talk talk wish you talk
talk wish you talk talk wish you just
talk to me I wish you talk talk wish you
talk talk you talk talk you talk to me I
think you're getting
closer cuz I'm getting
nervous I wish you wish you don't talk P
you don't talk P you just talk to me
talk to me talk to
me are you thinking about
me I'm kind of thinking you
are I followed you to the
bathroom but then I felt
crazy I'm feeling like I'm on
fire cuz we've been keeping this a
secret and all your friends are still
here and I'm just wondering what they
know
no I wish you talk wish you talk talk
you talk wish you talk to me I wish you
talk talk wish you talk talk you talk
talk you talk to me I think you're
getting
closer cuz I'm getting
nervous I wish you don't talk wish you
don't talk wish you don't talk wish you
talk to me talk to me to me she just to
me to me to me she just to me to
me to me to
me to me talk to me talk to me talk to
me in French talk to me in Spanish talk
to me in your made language doesn't
matter if I understand and talk right in
my ear tell me your secrets and fears
once you talk to me I talk to you and
say hey let's get out of here shall we
go back to my
[Music]
place hey friends I hope you enjoyed
this flow session goodness only knows I
enjoyed making it I rented a really cool
lens and went down and shot on the
National Mall and I thought the results
were pretty cool I hope you did too uh
real quickly um just want to put out a
huge thank you to the Friends of the
channel that is big thanks to dark monk
flow fests flow toys pyroar light toys
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video also special thanks to the non-
business friend of the channel That is
Becca Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission this video and all the videos on
this channel would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all so much
for your support and if you out there
watching uh are a fan of my work and
would like to see more of it you can
help me make more of it by heading on
over to patreon at patreon.com /
drexfactor poy and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission or bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out some more of the
POI performances that I have done over
the years I will go ahead and include a
link to a playlist of those videos down
in the description as well as up on
screen thank you so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow yourself
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace